hi we're going to uh
go through the an
on today and i used to feel very
embarrassed about this
i just thought i'd show you my
meditation store
this is for p people who want to
you know if you want to go in a
serious way you can do this rather than
a chair
so i thought i would just you know
park what i do as well
so that you can make no decision you can
buy these stores
from shore somewhere out there
they'll be selling them
but just just okay
so this is the stall that i use
when i want to i tap my chin
in this is i'm going a little deeper now
i'm telling you
took my chin in
relaxing
your knees are together
i normally hold one hand over the other
depending on
what you know how i feel and i just rest
them on my lap there's no
uh dude
like everything i've said so far you
need to be comfortable
now today i'm just going to show you the
sound of my
own and this is another form of uh i
think
going into a meditative state because
what you're doing is
while you're busy doing something
repetition
over and over it gives you like a trance
feeling
like a chanting uh some some
some people chant they keep going over
the same charm
same charm so this is um
to me meditation is a form of clearing
the mind
and becoming a peace with yourself
i had the bowl the other
one the other lessons so i'm going to
make sure my throat is comfortable
and i'm going to tell you some of the
hazards
either before or after
it happens i'm just going to do a few
of these arms and when i've taught it in
russia
between 100 and 200 people all in the
same room
we make this massive circle
and i tell people only on when you feel
like it
and and it comes from an
o sound from your throat
and at the end when your breath is
running out you just bring the lips
together the
lips vibrate a little into
you take a nice in breath if you find
it's hard work
and you're over doing it your throat may
feel here in your neck muscles
start to get tight or you may get a dry
throat and start to cough
don't worry about it it's just one of
those days you know
but the thing is not to try too hard
but to enjoy the on and the vibration it
gives you
it's like cleansing the inside of you
rather than the out
i will start with the sound of the bell
i will calm myself
go down inside myself relaxing deeper
and deeper as
the bell throbs away and then when i
stop hearing the bell i i'll start my
own
i'll only do a few for now so that
you're not
bored but you get the idea
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
whoa
boy
[Music]
then you gather yourself and you bring
yourself back
now they were very short
i was trying to give you an idea
of how you do the arm if your mouth or
your throat gets
a little dry in between the arms
just as the breath has come out
just move your tongue around your mouth
and get your saliva to
just wet your throat
if you want to wait a little bit and let
your breath
gather itself
perhaps let a breath miss a beat it
doesn't matter it's your own
and then when you're ready
oh
[Music]
okay you can experiment
you might want to make the the end part
longer
try both see what you enjoy
while you're busy doing that the mind's
empty
and you're just at first you're learning
this rhythm
after a while
10 minutes can pass really quick trust
me
and once you get in the rhythm and find
out how wonderful it is
you you'll start to just let it drift
and it'll be just like a
little machine just going over
and over in its own time okay
so you don't have to buy a meditation
stall
sitting here because perhaps
you know if you're not used to sitting
in this position
the pain in your ankles being
opened like they are
you know it may be too painful
if you don't head up you don't have your
head you'll notice i
feel like your chin's just tucked it a
little bit
spine is as straight as you can get it
shoulders are back
you can choose what hand
they normally say right over left for a
man
and left over right for a woman
but you know but you must feel
comfortable
let your breath be calm let it become
calm let your
facial muscles become calm
your throat muscles become calm
and only when you're ready don't worry
about the time factor
and don't be embarrassed if you're going
to be embarrassed don't do it
if you think you can do it without
disturbing others
please try it's a wonderful thing but
it's it's letting go
it's another fear that we might have as
a
human being
oh
[Music]
so okay try this enjoy it
and we'll keep going through different
systems of how we clear
our mind work on each piece
the more we enjoy it the more we'll
enjoy our peace
and find and start to find ourselves
more
but don't feel embarrassed about using
the chair that's what you need to use
if you want to buy one of these stores
it's at your expense it's up to you
they're quite expensive
but it depends how far you want to go
with the seriousness
of getting this cleansing system right
but i can do it in a chair i usually
find that it's better to
have the eyes closed
not available
[Music]
because i've been talking to you my
allowance
ain't being used so therefore
i'm finding it today that these arms are
short
another day it'll feel like i can
go on and on and on so
today is a day where i hope that you
found benefit in learning this
thank you for your time